[Music]
let's see what I've got how can we
improve explainability of AI models
there are lots of context whether it's
in legal context or um medical context
where you'd like to have explanations
and I think there are two fundamental
levels of which that happens at a low
level you want to be able to interrogate
a new network and decide which features
of an input are causing it to make a
certain decision and there's plenty of
work that's doing that so there are
methods like lime that was pioneered by
kis Western here at Stanford that are
looking at those kinds of explainability
in neural networks but I think a lot of
the time once we move to very large
neural networks we'd like a higher level
of explainability that the neural
network can actually just tell us why it
is making a certain decision and I think
that's a capability that we're actually
approaching with large language
models